you know the big thing in crypto these
days oh boy nfts oh yeah all i hear
about are these nfts i got maverick over
here who's probably gonna end up cutting
this clip yeah talks about nft's
non-stop i said let me do something for
maverick here we go i hear you know nfts
are here and you know what they ain't no
joke yeah they're they're they're like
the the alternative alternative kids
that are like okay i guess you're kind
of cool but you're kind of weird i don't
know enough about you i don't know i
don't know are you are you guys going to
take over the world or just like yeah
kill us all i'm not sure yet is this
just a jpeg
that's what's going on with nft so nft
wft
crypto
pvd opp you and me one two three
abc's
yeah
nft wtf so you hear these things all the
time crypto blockchain ledger digital
coin these are terms that like it's okay
if you don't understand these terms it's
okay to be like yeah i got no i i i got
nothing i do not understand yeah these
terms weren't even talked about a couple
years ago right especially nfts yeah no
nft i started hearing nft this year
exactly so if you're not familiar with
it that's okay but listen up for this
segment right here so block blockchain
it's all about the blockchain uh the
blockchain is like the one thing that
that everything in the crypto world the
bitcoin world the coinbase world
everything that these these digital
assets is based around this blockchain
it's basically like the stenographer
that's just constantly typing and
tracking everything that's going on
right cool so this is basically what
proves that these digital assets uh
can't be faked okay so nft non
fungible token fungible token fungible
you know what fungible means no fungent
idea no fungi idea replaceable go of
course non-functional can't be replaced
can't be duplicated never duplicated
always imitated yeah you feel me yeah
yeah i think that's run dmc right there
and then token what's a token it's like
basically a digital certificate sure
non-fungible token and ft
so um
[Music]
here's an example
you know because you said well why can't
i just take a freaking picture of you
know
take a picture of the freaking mona lisa
now i got a mona lisa on my phone but no
there's only one
mona lisa to use a very
clear art example and what an nft will
do is
you know authenticate this digital asset
in this case okay and authenticate this
one
digital asset called so there's a
million different
um
mona lisa posters out there but there's
only one mona lisa at the louvre in
paris yeah so basically what this uh nft
does is basically say nope this is the
original i bought i've authenticated it
that's what it is
okay but it's like the original what
jpeg
is that what it is it's like the
original jpeg it seems like you're not
in the nft train i i like i
look if it's a train and it's going
somewhere i go i'll get on it but it's
like
okay we all realize we're just creating
jpegs right okay well we're all on the
same page look because like okay so
you're telling me if pat pat um has a
big seller he has donald trump on the
podcast he takes a selfie right
that his picture yes and he sends it to
me so we both have a copy yeah but pat's
is the original one
that one's worth 40k
mine
though it's the same thing but it's not
the original is worth nothing this is
the question with nft so the nft but i
have the same question jack dorsey's
first tweet it was his first tweet on
twitter
yeah i know you can find it but someone
bought that as an nft for whatever you
know million dollars something
ridiculous whatever the number was
but they got they got the thing they get
the one thing
that's the whole point is that it's and
nf non-fungible can't be duplicated
it can be imitated
it can be imitated it can be imitated
but not duplicated there's the
difference
okay
i'm often often imitated never
duplicated
yeah if we're just trading stuff sure
let's do it but okay as long as we agree
this is all kind of i agree with you
that it's silliness yeah exactly but so
was bitcoin when it's first started well
i would no it was no i know no 2009
satoshi nakamoto's like yeah there's
going to be a digital crypto that
instead of using a dollar i'm just going
to people
people were trading in their bitcoin to
buy some pizza yeah i remember that okay
so i think okay so it's a little
different i learned listen david
listen
when the internet started whatever in
the 90s
exactly people were like people like the
internet what is this yeah everything
and then all these companies basically
that remember remember you were probably
too young but the dot-com boom the
bubble no i was like all these companies
were looking for i was paying attention
all these companies were getting crazy
valuations
right all these companies just because
they had com at the end of the name or
just basically had these crazy market uh
valuations worth millions and millions
and millions of dollars
boom people realize just because you got
com at the end of your company doesn't
make you a multi-millionaire billionaire
half the companies went bust didn't have
any profits made no freaking money
and they all went out of business and
then there was a dot-com bubble but
and here's the kicker here so they were
saying just like you were saying what is
this [ __ ] nft was it was a [ __ ]
no
you're that guy holy they all went
exactly
but here's my point
is the internet still here right are we
still doing email uh
social media here has things not gotten
way way way bigger than they were in
2000 so here's the point
i i don't think these digital assets
these digital coins this these nfts
these cryptos these blockchains and
bitcoins dude i don't think they're
going anywhere yeah and look there's
some
that might go out of business
there's some that might not be here sure
but just like the internet this shit's
not going anywhere and i agree listen
i'm not saying that it's not it's gonna
bust and it's not gonna work i'm not
saying that i'm just saying that things
like this is kind of just silly but
again as long as we all agree that we're
just trading jpegs then we're then i'm
good let's you know who's going to
disagree with you bro this 12 year old
coach yes how about this guy yeah he's
saying oh yeah you don't like my style
how you like me now here's the story for
you for speaking of ridiculousness in
the nft world yeah
12-year-old coder
earns nearly four hundred thousand
dollars in two months selling nft no i'm
out that's it your question yeah
no this
this feels kind of [ __ ] up now
david's out 12 years old 12 years old so
his name is ben yamin ahmed of course
of course it is i'm sorry of course he's
not your average 12 year old at five
years old ahmed began programming
uh after watching his father work as a
web developer nerdler oh my god imagine
your son being more successful than you
yeah that's what just happened here
you don't think the father's happy
but all of a sudden while doing his
programming watching it you know with
all due respect he's watching his father
as a web developer i'm sure you know
um
all of a sudden nfts catch his eye right
this is we talk about not being the old
man oh you young kids in your nfts right
dude you're 25 years old you should
probably be like hold on the one thing
that i'm not going to do for it here's
the deal
here's the deal the one thing i'm not
gonna do
is be late to the party anymore
i'm not gonna be late to the party i was
late to the party on everything okay i
had to play catch-up i was late to the
party on social media i was late to the
party on bitcoin i was late to the party
on just making money in general yeah but
eventually i caught up do you have an
nft tell me the truth tell me this
i've invested i need to know
i've actually invested in an nft
platform i don't own it oh that's right
yeah yeah you do i've invested in
something called ethernet
right shout out ethernet child ethernet
uh that's if you want to look into nfts
that's a great place to start ethernet
um so basically back to this guy
unbiased
it's a great place to start
uh his first so he launches this
collection he says his first nft
collection which he launched earlier
this summer
um consisted of 40 colorful avatars
called
minecraft yeehaw
right okay that i created after spending
too many hours playing the video game
minecraft that's what this kid says so
he says he's went to go sell this i know
you're about to [ __ ] freak out yeah
no he said the collection didn't sell
immediately
but that was
okay
he said he saw the project as more as a
learning experience than a money grab
right yeah
and he wanted to continue to create
and boy did he yeah so then after
launching um
earlier this summer right because he did
it he launched it then all of a sudden
the entire collection sold out in nine
hours because nft's basically been
popping lately
uh it's poppins
and uh
he said he made nearly 80 ether in one
day then he earned an additional 30
ether shortly after that and he now
earns two and a half percent royalty on
each secondary sale
uh the bottom line he keeps making money
as other people trade it yeah royalties
okay uh
yeah gur what the hell is happening
right here so so you made minecraft png
jpegs whatever you want to call it so
and he's like here's my point here's my
point tell me just how you're like
what's your point with that though
thank you pbd that's on cue here's my
point when i talked about you know not
being late to the game anymore maybe
being an early adapter i missed i
remember people telling me about
bitcoin in like 2014. i'm like dude i'm
like
not even trying to hear what you're
saying right now i'm just starting to
make real money yeah for the first time
in my life yeah dude like i have like
real stuff going on now you want to talk
about this
fake digital money i'm good dude
had i listened i'd be worth way more
right now so ask yourself are you just
saying oh i don't get it i'm not going
to pay attention are you being an old
crotchety no ornery old man no or are
you just don't get it and you want to be
a hater i'm not saying you i'm saying to
people at home right
but my whole thing is um
not being late to the game anymore i do
not like if something is new and it's
fresh and it's cutting edge i don't want
to be that guy that's like
well i don't get it all these kids these
days i want to say oh what's up nft okay
cool tell me i don't know spongebob i
never heard what a fungible thing is but
yeah i like fun i like fun i like i like
edibles fun fun edibles that's great
sign me up yeah exactly and now i'm
getting fungibles and that's what i
think you should be doing with nfts it's
not dismissing it from your vocabulary
embrace it yes because i don't think
it's going anywhere is it a bubble maybe
but i don't think it's going anywhere i
100 agree i just think what's the next
thing like
next thing um people are selling air
bags of air
went for a 400k well
yeah i agree well i remember there was a
time when people sold pet rocks oh you
see my rock
do you remember those days yeah it's
true anyway nfts aren't going anywhere
so again it's that it's that it's that
internet 2.0 thing
um
with that being said yeah let's just
give some disclaimers to nfts and it's
not all it's not all um butterflies and
rainbows and board apes out there
there's some things you need to know
about nft so here's this other article
right there this is the one thing that
nobody wants to talk about when it comes
to nfts yes you can make money yes that
you know it's uh it's trading pretty
high um
so this is a warning to and to all the
buyers and sellers and players out there
in the nft marketplace so you can make
your money
right make that money but understand
that there's a sneaky sneaky beast
coming your way and that beast is called
uncle sam aka
the tax man oh here comes dad here comes
dad ruining the party hey kids it's time
to pay up
so as people buy sell and trade nfts
these assets will become important and
important plot points in your tax
records nobody likes taxes oh no right
well that being with this being such a
new market there are a lot of questions
and uncertainties about how these assets
will be viewed during
tax season here's an example and and i
and i read this and i had to check it
and source it and read the article again
and this is exactly what it says
on this article from 1 37 p.m that's the
name of the website it says for example
let's say you buy an nft
for 10 000
and then you sell it
for a million dollars you know how much
you would owe in taxes you know what
uncle sam would want from that how much
how about a half a million dollars
what jesus
what
that's like it's kind of like when you
went on a game show where you win the
lottery you owe 50 taxes is that what
this is
okay i don't know maybe that's ordinary
income tax i don't know what that is if
maybe it was capital gains it'd be
less than that 20 i don't know but a
half a million dollars to this so let
that sink in for a second taxes are no
joke talk is money
all we talk is money
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sauce cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broke